winter in Berlin in 2022 it's a cold and
dark time with Energy prices elevated by
the war in Ukraine for some people there
are few ways to keep warm so the heated
shelters are busy there's a feeling
mentioned in Berlin so many people in
Berlin but also elsewhere have so little
money that they turn off the heating in
their apartment or only turn it on for
hours at a time and that's where it's
particularly important that during the
day there are also places in the city
where you can stay in the warmth
until 2022 Germany received much of its
imported gas through pipelines from
Russia now that route is closed off and
this is its replacement a floating LNG
terminal in wilhemshaven built from
scratch in months at the behest of a
Chancellor determined to break with the
past
Lance president Russell's President
Putin believed he could blackmail Us by
cutting off our gas supplies but he was
wrong we will not be a blackmailed by
the end of 2023 we will probably have an
important capacity of more than 30
billion cubic meters of gas via the
north German Coast alone
all of this corresponds to well over
half of the total volume of gas that
flowed through the pipelines from Russia
to Germany in 2021.
replacing lost Russian hydrocarbons has
been a central problem for Europe's
leaders in 2022 the EU has introduced
embargoes on coal and oil a cap on gas
prices has just been agreed and will
start in February and one brussels-based
analyst says EU leaders could agree to
purchase gas as one block with one
negotiating position if you represent
400 million citizens you're talking
volumes that are very very large and
these volumes of course you can get as
some sort of discount and that of course
will have an effect on on the on the
consumer prices as well but again this
is going to last at least a few months
probably it will if you get through and
if it's being implemented which also uh
you know has legal administrative
hurdles to to pass then it will will
have an effect on on on the gas price in
the next winter
at Christmas markets like these most
people's minds are far from volatile
energy markets mulled wine pastries and
presents are the order of the day
when the festive season passes these
markets will disappear and winter will
not and though ministers encourage their
citizens to reduce their energy
consumption many might wonder how easy
it is to do that in the cold and dark
days of a New Year Donna Kane Al Jazeera
Berlin